5 6 1 de 20 25 ans sa longévité au
festival darc alain lopez de la croûte
même pli parmi la trentaine de
professeurs qui fait partie des anciens
une fidélité abîmé par l' envie de
transmettre ça fait 40 ans que
j'enseigne j'en apprends tous les jours
j'en apprends par les élèves
ce qu'on aime c'est enseigner donc des
fois un seul mot suffit pour que
quelqu'un en comprenne
chaque personne différente il faut
trouver le bon mot pour qu'ils
comprennent et là on arrive à faire des
exploits
bel exploit certainement et des
vocations sûrement camilla 23 ans dont
14 de dark au festival c'est une simple
stagiaire
mais dans la vie elle est professeur de
danse un parcours mais ici grâce à un
coup de pouce familiale
ma maman est prof de danse et c'est elle
qui m'a amené à me rends au stage je
pense que ça a été une sorte de déclic
en voyant la façon d'enseigner de
certains professeurs je me suis dit que
plus de 600 stagiaires de 12 âge et du
monde entier
il va t'elle de cours de danse pour tous
les niveaux durant cette 40e édition il
y a de quoi voir la famille parc
s'agrandir
d